généreux bonjour cette question de la
neutralité qu'il dit désormais étudier
très sérieusement
elle est pas nouvelle mais on semble
quand même malgré tout qu'elle devient
si ce n'est la clé des discussions une
bonne base des changes en tout cas
absolument l'équivalent en fait de la
neutralité c'est le fait que l'ukraine
n'adhère pas à l'otan or on le sait
c'était une des principales
revendications de
vladimir poutine et le président
ukrainien il ya fait référence alors il
a dit le président ukrainien à plusieurs
reprises que finalement l'adhésion à
l'otan n'était plus forcément envisagé
et maintenant il va plus loin en disant
neutralité de neutralité c'est la
troisième fois maintenant qu'ils en
parlent alors ça veut dire quoi prenons
des exemples en europe il n'ya des pays
européens qui pourtant tout en étant
membre par exemple de l'union européenne
sont neutres neutre militairement ça
veut dire qu'il ne n'adhère pas à une
alliance militaire en l'occurrence à
l'otan et que par ailleurs ils n'ont pas
de troupes étrangères de troupes de
soldats étrangers sur leur sol c'est le
cas par exemple de la finlande de la
suède ou encore de l'autriche c'est des
statuts qui ont été hérités et décidée
après la première la deuxième guerre
mondiale par pardon au moment de la
naissance de la guerre froide donc ça
c'est peut-être des modèles qui
pourraient inspirer ce qui se passe en
ukraine en ce moment les points
d'achoppement de quand même c'est enfin
c'est pour ça que c'est peut-être pas
juste une question d'heures ou de jours
ça va être négociés sur le long terme
c'est que en échange le président
ukrainien veut des garanties absolues
pour la sécurité et la souveraineté de
son pays et des garanties par des pays
étrangers à savoir des pays européens et
c'est là dessus que les discussions
certainement vont devoir porter alors on
sait qu'ils l'aimeraient bien
s'entretenir en direct avec vladimir
poutine sergueï lavrov chef de la
diplomatie russe qui est en train de
s'exprimer vient des quartiers en tout
cas pour le moment cette hypothèse
qu'ils estiment qu'elle serait contre
productif par n'ont peut-être des russes
on sent bien que les lignes ci sont sont
un peu en train de bouger au tout début
de cette cette guerre vladimir poutine
avait fixé pour ambition de des nazis
fier des minutes arisée l'intégralité du
pays de faire tomber aussi le goût volot
d'imaginer ce qui on en n'est plus du
tout là aujourd'hui où absolument dans
le narratif on a complètement changé
alors il parle de concentration des
troupes russes maintenant vers le
dombass est ce que c'est juste de la
propagande destinée à son opinion
publique des pays neutres est ce que
c'est la recherche une porte de sortie
honorable
suite à un enlisement militaire vous
savez que effectivement cessé ses
troupes russes n'ont pas avancé aussi
rapidement et n'ont pas pris les villes
qu'elle souhaitait prendre au départ
alors sur le terrain il faut rester
prudent même si on parle de
contre-attaqué de contre-offensive une
craie nian les services de renseignement
britanniques par exemple on dit ne pas
voir de changement notable ces 24
dernières heures
mais concernant le don bas ce qui est
certain c'est que de la même façon que
vladimir poutine avait dit qu'il
souhaitait que l'ukraine n'adhère pas à
l'otan il a aussi soutenu depuis le
début l'autonomie voire l'indépendance
des provinces est de 2,2 l'ukraine ça
fait partie de son art hâtif de guerre
d'ailleurs de dire qu'il est allé sauver
des populations du sceau phone de ces
provinces de ces provinces depuis 2015
elles sont dans un statut
intermédiaire il ya eu un référendum en
2014 où elles se sont autoproclamés
indépendance qui n'a pas enfin autonome
ce qui n'a pas été reconnue par la
communauté internationale
mais effectivement peut-être qu'il va
essayer de concentrer ses objectifs
politiques sur ces ces deux provinces
pour les rendre peut-être indépendante
de la même façon que la crimée l'a été
en 2014 une autre version peut être plus
pessimistes de ce scénario c'est
finalement sa masquerait tout simplement
la volonté de séparer ou de morceler
l'ukraine en deux zones en deux pays
comme ça a été le cas par exemple de la
corée ou de l'allemagne pendant la
guerre froide avec l'est sous influence
russe et l'ouest sous influence
occidentale
voilà pour ses scénarios aussi merci
beaucoup virginie pour le décryptage
alors ok